Вітаю вас, друзі.
Ви на уроці фізики для сьомого класу.
Тема сьогоднішнього уроку:
Сполучені посудини. Манометри.
На минулих уроках ми з
вами розглянули тиск рідин,
формулу для обчислення
гідростатичного тиску
та поговорили про атмосферний тиск.
Багато з цих питань пояснюють
велику кількість фізичних явищ,
які навколо нас можна спостерігати.
І зараз я для початку
продемонструю вам один із них.
Дивіться, у нас є пляшка,
яка зараз закоркована.
В ній знаходиться звичайна
водичка, над нею трошки повітря.
І є у нас три корки – це три отвори,
закриті цими корками на різних рівнях.
Зараз я скористаюсь лише одним із них.
Як ви вважаєте, що буде, якщо я
витягну, наприклад, середній корок?
Ось дивітся, я відкриваю корок
і ми бачимо, що незважаючи
на те, що там є чималий отвір,
вода не виливається з цієї пляшки
і нічого не заходить.
В чому секрет?
Ми вже говорили про
існування атмосферного тиску.
Зрозуміло, що секрет полягає
в тому, що тут рівновага.
Сила тиску з боку атмосфери
і сила тиску, який створює
ось цей стовпчик рідини
і повітря, яке знаходиться над ним –
вони будуть врівноважені.
Але як тільки я відкрию –
рідина з цієї пляшки
починає жваво виходити.
При перекриванні струмінь тут же зникає.
Дивіться.
Коли рідина наливається в посудину,
її вільна поверхня
якимось чином розбігається
і можна знаходити деякі закономірності.
Можна організувати посудини,
які будуть між собою
з`єднані якимось каналом.
Нехай це будуть циліндричні посудини,
вони не обов`язково повинні
бути однакових розмірів.
Нехай ось тут внизу я їх з`єднаю
такою трубочкою невеличкою.
Припустимо собі,
що тут у нас є можливість
поставити краник,
який перекриє ось цю трубку,
поки що вона знаходиться
в стані перекритому.
І припустимо собі, що я
наливаю в цю посудину
і в цю посудину якусь рідину,
ця рідина знаходиться в лівому
і в правому коліні цієї
посудини на різних висотах.
Нехай ця висота буде позначена h1,
а ось ця h2.
Нагадаю, що рідина у нас одна і та сама.
Її густина «Ро».
Давайте спрогнозуємо що буде,
якщо ми відкриємо цей корок?
Якщо тут буде відкрито,
то пересування рідини вліво чи
вправо буде залежати від того,
який тиск буде з однієї сторони і
з іншої сторони цього перекриття.
А тиски, ми знаємо, можна обчислити
за формулою гідростатичного тиску
(Р = «ро»*g*h).
Крім того, це посудини,
відкриті в атмосферу
і з минулого уроку ви знаєте, що сама
атмосфера, що створює певний тиск
(позначим його Р з індексом а).
Загальний тиск, який буде
з лівої сторони від цього –
це буде Р атмосфери плюс «ро»*g*h1.
З правого боку – це буде
«ро»*g*h2 + Р атмосфери.
Оскільки висота h2 менше ніж висота h1,
то тиск з цього боку
(я поставлю крапочку, напишу Р2),
а ось тут тиск Р1.
Тиск Р1 буде більшим ніж тиск Р2.
Тому при відкриванні
потік рідини буде зліва направо.
До чого це буде приводити?
Це буде приводити, що
рівень води в посудині зліва буде
опускатись, а справа буде підніматись.
І завершиться ця історія тоді,
коли встановляться рівновага тисків.
Коли Р1 буде рівним Р2.
Давайте запишемо цей момент.
В момент рівноваги
тиски Р1 буде рівний тиску Р2.
Тиски врівноважились, вони стали рівними.
Розпишемо з цієї формули.
«ро»*g*h1 + Р атмосфери
буде рівний тиску в
правому коліні цієї посудини
«ро»*g*h2 + Р атмосфери.
Бачимо, що ці доданки можна
прибрати, вони скорочуються
і так само можна буде
скоротити на «ро» і g.
І ми приходимо до висновку,
що h1 буде рівний h2.
Тобто рівновага буде спостерігатись тоді,
коли рівні в цих посудинах
будуть однаковими.
Це і є основна властивість
сполучених посудин.
Давайте її запишемо у ваші зошити.
У відкритих сполучених посудинах
вільні поверхні однорідної
нерухомої рідини
встановлюються на одному рівні.
Спробуємо в цьому переконатись.
Запрошую поспостерігати
за ось цим приладом.
Чи можна назвати цю посудину
елементом сполучених посудин?
Цілком.
Це така трубка, вона у
вигляді прямокутної літери О.
Зверху є відкритий отвір і
він сполучений з атмосферою.
Ліва сторона і права сторона - часто
називають ліве і праве коліно цієї трубки.
Дивіться, зараз вони знаходяться
на однаковій висоті і ці висоти рівні.
Якщо я буду нахиляти цю посудину –
то ви бачите, при всій
складності ситуації,
рідина переміщується, завжди
залишаючись на одному рівні.
Бачите?
От щось подібне відбувається, скажімо,
в сполучених посудинах, які ми
тримаємо кожного ранку в руках,
наприклад, чайник заварний для чаю.
Коли ми нахиляємо його для того,
щоб з носика виливалася рідина,
завжди рідина в цьому
чайнику буде знаходитись
на одному рівні в носику
і в самому чайнику.
Я приготував вам такий малюночок чайника.
Якщо зараз тут рівень рідини ось такий,
то коли я його буду нахиляти,
він все одно буде залишатись в носику
і в самому чайнику на одному рівні.
Я зафіксую, наприклад, це положення.
Нехай він знаходиться тут.
Ось цей рівень.
А якщо би я нахилив нижче,
або цей рівень вже був
перевищений і був ось такий –
це означає, що носик якраз
вже буде готовий наливати нам
рідину з цього заварничка.
Якщо ви будете уважними, то побачите,
що в цій формулі нічого складного немає.
Вона говорить про рівність висот і тут
ніде не фігурує форма самої посудини.
Чи вона буде з вертикальними стінками,
чи вона має володіти якимись
іншими характеристикам.
Тому цей феномен
можна спостерігати і для посудин,
які мають досить дивну форму.
Ось дивіться, у нас є сполучення посудини,
які мають три типи різних
форм, крім циліндричного.
Я заливаю рідину.
По мірі наливання, рівень
цієї рідини піднімається вгору.
Єдине, що нам може суттєво тут
заважати – це бульбашки рідини, які там є.
Ну сподіваюсь, що вони поспливають.
Не буду більше збільшувати.
Ось гляньте.
Бачите - рівень рідини в усіх посудинах,
незважаючи на їх чудернацьку
форму, буде однаковий.
Сполучення посудин.
Цікаве застосування
феномену сполучених посудин
можна побачити на ось цьому приладі.
Дивіться.
У нас є дві склянки, заповнені
підфарбованою рідиною
і в неї опущена трубочка,
в якій знаходиться ця сама рідина,
немає ніяких повітряних
бульбашок і прошарок.
Для того, щоб ви розуміли, що
воно знаходиться на одному рівні,
я поставлю на допомогу ось цю указочку.
Бачите, що рівні справді однакові?
Тепер я спробую збільшити висоту,
скажімо ось цього правого стаканчика.
Дивіться, я піднімаю його,
наприклад, до рівня цієї указочки.
І ви можете сказати: «О, не працює закон».
Посудини є, вони сполучені,
але рівні їх не однакові.
Але ми говорили про нерухому рідину.
Дивіться, виявляється
зараз рідина є рухомою.
Якщо ви були спостережливими, то
побачили, що тут рівень води понижується,
а там підвищується.
І зупиниться це тоді, коли
вони вирівняються знову ж таки.
Що саме цікаве? Дивіться.
Оскільки тут збільшується рівень, а
тут зменшується – це означає, що рідина
піднімається вгору
незважаючи на дії сили тяжіння.
Вона йде долаючи силу тяжіння,
перетікаючи в іншу посудину.
Видно, що вони на одному рівні?
Ну, мабуть так.
Якщо я опущу знову ж таки цей
столик на попереднє положення,
то перетікання рідини буде
відбуватись в протилежному напрямку.
І припиниться цей процес
поки рівні не вирівняються
і не стануть однаковими по формі лінієчки.
Ще одне цікаве застосування цього ефекту
ви точно маєте в кожному
з будівельних магазинів.
Зараз я вам покажу.
Якщо взяти трубку, в якій
налито знову ж таки рідину,
ми її знову підфарбували,
щоб ви бачили рівно,
то використання цього пристрою
в будівництві є неоціненним.
Що ж можна ним поміряти
або як його можна використати?
Ми вже сказали, що це трубка,
по суті діла сполучені посудини,
і рівень буде знаходитись
на однаковому рівні –
в правій і в лівій частини цієї трубки.
Це означає, якщо мені, наприклад,
потрібно виставити ось цей штатив
на такій самій висоті як ось цей –
то мені достатньо тримати
цю трубку біля цього штатива
і потім той штатив виставити
по рівню в цій трубці.
Я буду мати гарантію, що вони знаходяться
в просторі на однаковій висоті.
І ще одна цікавинка для вас.
Ось така весела трубочка.
Часто в наших оселях знаходиться
під умивальниками, рукомийниками.
Як же ця штука працює?
Уявіть собі, що тут зверху
знаходиться умивальник.
Коли ми помили руки, водичка стікає сюди,
піднімається вгору, стікає туди і пройшла.
І ось тут буде знаходитись в цьому
коліні, вона буде знаходитись постійно,
перекриваючи тим самим
повітря, яке не бажане
із запахами, ароматами,
яке могло би проходити через
цей канал до нас в кімнату ванну.
Це такий захист для нас
проти таких неприємних запахів.
Використання сполучених
посудин дуже ефективно
можна застосовувати в
приладах для вимірювання тиску
і такими приладами є рідинні манометри.
Це трубочка, яка має
форму латинської літери U,
тому її називають U-подібна трубка.
В неї налита рідина
і якщо край однієї і другої трубки
відкрити в атмосферу, наприклад,
то рівень цієї рідини однаковий.
При збільшенні тиску одного з країв,
наприклад, я зараз спробую сюди подути,
вона сполучена з трубочкою з
лівим коліном U-подібної трубки.
Дивіться.
Зрозуміло, що я збільшую тиск, він
стає тепер більшим ніж атмосферний
і тоді він разом із тиском гідростатичним
стовпчика рідини в лівому коліні
повинен бути врівноважений
тиском атмосферним і
гідростатичним в правому коліні.
Оскільки той тиск, який я зараз створив
надлишковий, більший ніж атмосферний,
це приводить до зміни рівнів в
цьому лівому і правому коліні.
Давайте спробуємо розв`язати
експериментальну задачку.
Для цього ми спробуємо використати
ось цей манометр для вимірювання тиску
повітря, який буде ось в цій колбі.
Зараз колба відкрита.
Бачите, цей краник - він її сполучає з
атмосферою, тиск там атмосферний.
Спробую трошки його збільшити.
Трошки збільшив тиск в
цій колбі і перекрив краник.
Тепер я сполучаю трубочкою
колбу з лівим коліном нашого манометра,
починаю відкривати краник,
щоб не дало поштовхом і ця
рідина не вийшла за межі трубочки.
Ось так. Краник відкритий.
Як бачите,
рівень рідини в лівому і
правому коліні відрізняється.
В лівому коліні, який
з`єднаний з цією колбою,
тиск більший над рідиною,
тому рівні не збігаються.
Давайте спробуємо вивести формулу,
яка б дозволила порахувати
наскільки тиск у колбі зараз
буде більший, ніж атмосферний.
Бачите, така трубка має
форму літери «U» англійської.
В англійській мові її так
і називають U-shaped,
тобто U-подібна трубка.
Припустимо собі, що ось це
був початковий рівень рідини,
коли вона була на однакових
рівнях зліва і справа.
Це називається ліве коліно,
це відповідно праве.
Давайте подивимось, яке у
нас коліно відкрите в атмосферу.
Ота трубочка, яка знаходиться
праворуч, бачите вона відкрита,
тобто над нею і над
рідиною атмосферний тиск.
Ми напишемо, що тут тиск атмосферний.
Оскільки площа поперечного
перерізу трубочки всюди однакова,
то коли там тиск був збільшений –
то воно натискає на рідину,
рідина опускається нижче початкового.
А в цьому коліні вона піднімається, але
на такий самий рівень, як тут опустилось.
Оце буде перепад рівню –
позначимо їх дельта h.
Ця частина трубки приєднана
до склянки в лівому коліні
і там буде тиск (Р) з
індексом українське «п» -
це тиск в посудині.
З умови рівноваги ось тут в цьому місці,
сума тисків, які є в лівому коліні,
добутку на площу поперечного перерізу буде
створювати силу тиску направлену праворуч.
А сума тисків в правому
коліні, в добутку на цю площу,
буде створювати силу
тиску, яка діє ліворуч.
Якщо у нас встановилась
рівновага - то ці сили будуть однакові
і при умові однакових площ,
звісно, будуть однакові тиски.
Я напишу так - тиск в лівому
коліні буде рівний тиску в правому.
Який у нас тиск в лівому коліні?
Він складається з тиску, який є в
посудині, в нашому випадку в колбі,
плюс тиск ось цього стовпчика рідини –
я його позначу h1.
За формулою гідростатичного
тиску (на дошці) це буде «ро»*g*h1.
З іншого боку, з правої сторони, у
нас над рідиною атмосферний тиск
і тиск ось цього стовпчика рідини,
давайте його якось позначимо
h2.
Дивимось - формула на дошці!
Наша мета знайти тиск в посудині.
Тому я перенесу цей доданок
праворуч – тиск в посудині буде рівним.
Тиск атмосферний
плюс «ро»*g*h2
мінус «ро»*g*h1.
В цьому місці зручно
винести спільний множник –
це добуток густини на
прискорення вільного падіння,
і в дужечках ми будемо
мати різницю висот (h2 - h1),
яку ми з вами позначили
літерою дельта h – це різниця висот.
Давайте ми ще тут
допишемо: дельта h = h2 - h1.
В результаті тиск в посудині
буде більшим від атмосферного
на величину «ро»*g*дельта h.
Якщо би ми зараз взяли лінійку
і виміряли довжину стовпчиків h1; h2,
або ще простіше одразу можна
виміряти різницю між рівнями дельта h,
то обчислення могли би нам
дати значення тиску в цій посудині.
Ось такий цікавий приклад.
Поки я не прибрав
установку, хочу вас запитати.
А якби в колбі тиск був
менший ніж атмосферний?
До чого привело би відкривання краника?
Абсолютно вірно.
В цьому випадку у нас для рівності
тисків в лівому і в правому коліні,
ось цей тиск якщо б в посудині
був би менший атмосферний,
то тоді h1 у нас було би більшим ніж h2.
І рідина от цього початкового рівня,
давайте я так покажу,
наприклад - це початковий рівень,
при відкриванні краника
тут рідина буде підніматись,
а тут буде опускатись.
Це означає, що тиск атмосферний
більший, ніж той, що є в посудині,
тому воно продавлює цю рідину,
просуваючи її в ліву частину коліна.
В нашому випадку на цій установці
ми мали справу з однаковою рідиною.
А чи можуть бути випадки,
коли в лівому і в правому коліні
будуть знаходитись інші речовини,
різні рідини, які не змішуються, бо
саме тоді це буде зручно обчислити.
Давайте ми розглянемо такого типу задачу.
У ліве коліно U-подібної
трубки, заповненої водою,
доливають шар олії висотою 25 см.
На скільки будуть відрізнятися
рівні поверхонь води?
Густина олії 800 кг/м3.
Дивіться, оце вільна поверхня
води в лівому коліні (наведу жирніше),
а це в правому.
До того, як ми долили олію,
вони були на одному рівні.
Після доливання олії, шар олії,
створюючи гідростатичний тиск,
притиснув воду і вона
піднялася в правому коліні.
Різниця рівню – дельта h.
Це те, що нам зараз потрібно знайти.
Розв`язуючи попередню задачу,
ми використовували рівність
тисків ось в цьому місці,
бо сила тиску зліва і
справа були однаковими.
Зрозуміло, що якщо ми маємо в
лівому і в правому коліні рідину однакову
(я покажу указочкою),
то на однакових рівнях цієї рідини
ми будемо мати однаковий тиск.
Тому, дійшовши до цього рівня,
тиск в цій точці
і цій точці однаковий.
Тому можемо прирівнювати
тиски на ось цьому рівні.
Як це можна довести
було б на якісному рівні?
Дивіться, в лівому і в правому коліні,
з цієї і з цієї сторони тиски однакові.
При зануренні в рідину
тиск збільшується на величину
гідростатичного тиску («ро»*g*h).
Але якщо я піднімаюся
на якусь висоту в рідині,
тиск буде відповідно на таку
саму величину зменшуватись.
Тому виходить, якщо тиски
ось тут і ось тут однакові,
то піднявшись на однакову величину h,
тиск ось тут і ось тут в цих колінах
буде менший чим той, що
внизу, на величину «ро»*g*h.
Але поскільки це одна і та сама рідина,
густини однакові і однакові висоти,
то і відповідно тут тиски будуть однакові.
Тому, запам`ятайте, це можна
використовувати при розв`язуванні задач.
Якщо у вас в U-подібній трубці десь
є нижній шар з однаковою рідиною,
то можна її відкинути і брати до
розв`язку, до уваги в розв’язуванні задачі
рівність тисків до того місця, коли вже
починаються відмінності між рідинами.
Записуємо рівність тисків
в лівому і в правому коліні
на ось цьому зазначеному
пунктирною лінією.
В лівому коліні тиск олії
плюс той тиск, який є згори,
а вгорі в нас є атмосферний тиск,
бо ця посудина відкрита в
атмосферу зліва і справа.
А в правому коліні на
цьому рівні, ось в цій точці,
тиск можна обчислювати, як
гідростатичний тиск цього шару води
(я запишу тиск води),
плюс тиск, який є ось тут над
рідиною, а він також атмосферний.
І оскільки в нас
спостерігається рівновага,
то ці тиски в лівому і
правому коліні однакові.
На атмосферний тиск можна скоротити,
а оці тиски ми можемо розписати.
Давайте я запишу формулу для
гідростатичного тиску: Р = «ро»*g*h.
Підставляючи сюди, я буду
бачити, що з цього буде слідувати.
Тиск олії, це буде густина
олії помножити на g і на h олії.
А з цього боку, тиск який
створює оцей стовпчик води –
це буде густина помножити
на прискорення вільного падіння
і на висоту стовпчика води над цим рівнем,
який ми позначили в
нашій задачі як дельта h –
це різниця рівнів верхніх поверхонь
рідини (тому я тут допишу літеру дельта).
На прискорення вільного
падіння можна скоротити.
І звідси виражаємо те, що
нам потрібно знайти - дельта h.
Розділимо ліву і праву частину на
густину води і отримаємо таку формулу –
«ро» олії на h олії і
розділити на густину води.
Ось ми отримали кінцеву
формулу для цієї задачки.
і тепер давайте її обчислимо.
Чому ж рівна дельта h?
Густина олії, за умовою, 800 кг/м3;
висота стовпчика олії 25 см
і густина води 1000 кг на м3.
Зверніть увагу,
оскільки тут іде відношення
густин, то їх розмірності скорочуються
і єдина розмірність, яка у нас
залишається – це сантиметри.
Ми отримали 20 см.
Це і буде відповідь нашій задачі.
Ми прекрасно з вами сьогодні попрацювали.
Я вам бажаю всього
найкращого і до нових зустрічей!